nice bang bang Brian's here we got a lot
to talk about
yes sir are you ready he flew all the
way from LA just for this not really not
true but we're gonna run with it alright
you've done a whole bunch of [ __ ] in
your life let's jump right into tinder
you are the now known but at the time
somewhat unknown architect of making
tinder the highest-grossing app in the
[ __ ] App Store tinder was being used
by millions of people but making $0 and
it went from that to being used by tens
of millions of people and making so much
money that it's not fattening bull for
most entrepreneurs what happened like
what did you guys do yeah well first is
it wasn't all me great team certainly a
lot of hard work from a lot of people I
think what's interesting about the the
tinder story is sort of we went accross
we went we sort of went against every
conceivable norm in what way at that
point in time dating first was was small
the Tam of dating was perceived as as
you know something that the mature
internet companies wouldn't find
interesting second the the dating
industry was essentially a paywall
industry you would go in potentially set
up a profile and bang second a message
came through it would be you know pay us
we took a very different approach and we
thought of dating as content as an
experience as entertainment and when you
think of something like that why would
you want to put a paywall in front of it
so instead of inventing a better design
way to push someone through the
subscription funnel we said how do we
extend behaviors that we already saw on
the platform and productize it and so
this isn't right now I guess this is
considered sort of like you know a
pattern that a lot of people follow
because of
the success of the app but at the time
it didn't feel irrational it felt like
the right thing to do so instead of you
know saying pay us 19 bucks a month we
wanted to introduce you to a super like
who would give you one free so would you
get a taste of it you would feel that
emotional energy of sending off a super
like or even better receiving one and
then you would sort of you know you
start to make that association of these
these little subtle super super powers
are going to help me have a better
overall experience so what you really
did it sounds like as you took things
that people are already doing they were
used to using the application for liking
swiping all this kind of stuff and when
you say you extended them give us some
examples of like what those actually
look like it's like what is a super like
and what are some of the other things
you guys did yeah so let's let's start
sort of from the top
people want cheat codes in life and you
know this is a gaming industry term but
when you think about tinder it really is
a game of it's a variable reward game
swipe swipe swipe match oh my gosh that
was amazing so I swipe swipe hopefully
another match so what we wanted to do is
really take this idea of variable
rewards and then sort of pack them
inside of this core experience alongside
of also giving people these sort of
pseudo cheat codes so if you think about
tin or gold it allows you to see who's
right swiped on you that helps you get
to the sort of meat of the application
faster and if you're serious about
dating you're serious about meeting
people you want that edge so instead of
you know creating a system that was very
draconian and sort of 1998 we took a lot
of things from the gaming industry and a
lot of things from a lot of the user
behaviors that were already embedded in
our application it's not like we sat
down and said hmm I wonder how we can
monetize this we knew people wanted to
stand out we knew people wanted to go
from A to B faster you know we knew what
people wanted to understand how to
manipulate their experience so we just
gave it to him and we did it in a very
subtle way but in a way where a lot of
people saw these paywalls and as we all
know conversion is subject to how many
times you see a paywall and we didn't do
it in a fashion that was super
aggressive and like made people mad
it was away
where people saw it as as an opportunity
on the platform rather than attacks it
almost feels like they don't think that
of it as a paywall right like if I go to
a media site and I get here at the
paywall it's a [ __ ] paywall because
exactly there's content that I wanted to
read but I must feel tricked right it's
like hey I clicked on the link and I
thought I already had the article and
then BAM I get hit and so is like a
negative experience because now it's
Amelie you took it away from me until I
give that money right whereas what you
guys did is you presented it and it was
like an easter egg they discuss yeah we
think of it that we internally as an
achievement so you look at this sort of
dichotomy between the words of you know
a paywall or some forced action or an
achievement that you can unlock everyone
wants an achievement everyone wants to
go a little further in the game and so I
think the other thing that we focused on
is like ridiculous simplicity with
monetization another product that we
launched it was extremely successful
it's called boost boost just shows you
two more people very simple concept not
a lot of mental energy that you would
need to understand what this does and it
was one time
do I know before I get the boost
functionality do I know hey I'm only
being shown to 10% of the people like
was it measured well yeah there's a
little user education I think what what
happens is the proof is in the pudding
you get more right swipes yeah more
people like you and you immediately you
have this this delightful experience and
you look at the Delta and you say well
that was because I purchased boosts and
so when you can tie cause-and-effect
together and a consumer tool big things
happen yeah big things happen
super like boost what else top picks I
mean there's it there's tons and tons of
different ones some smaller and some
more important than others but I think
like the theme always is simple products
so if you think about even the branding
tinder super like it's you really like
them
tinder boost be exposed to more people
tinder gold towards a positive and it's
always positive it's always aspirational
and again this goes back to sort of my
product theory about no mind
you don't educate the customer they have
to come to the conclusion about what
you're selling them immediately on their
own why would you spend time doing all
these things that people think you know
this is super smart just give them
something very simple digestible
achievable and most times customers will
at you be astonished what you can
actually achieve so you I came to them I
say I love you but you're probably the
best product person I know you have a
bunch of these frameworks that you've
just implemented over and over and over
again in your career most people
listening to this have no clue what any
of this is right or they're coming at
the understand product they don't
understand kind of your framework so no
mind for example explain what that is
because I think that's one of the core
things that you believe in that others
might not even know that is sure so we
live all of us very busy lives we have
our schedules our routines we fall we
all do certain things we watch reality
television we scroll mindlessly through
Instagram people are somewhat
predictable and when I talk about no
mind I talk about we always I'm sure
you've heard of the term of the wedge
right everyone always talks about what
is the wedge of this product or the
service right what people are really
saying is how do you pierce into
someone's attention stream and get them
to change your behavior or modify it
such that they're using your product or
service very hard to do because really
I'm gonna say it right here nobody cares
no one wants your product no one needs
your product it has to find them how you
find people first even above no mind is
ultra simplicity people are not going to
give you attention unless something is
very digestible that means that means
perfect copy that means a you know
really good visual branding that means
an understanding of who the customer is
and where they live and being able to
get to them in their natural environment
second and this is sort of my
overarching theory about kind of
consumer products they've succeeded
it's just something called no mind
people do not want to use your service
and think they want the service to come
to them so we see this whole culture
right now you know we call it you know
Auto streaming or autoplay or whatever
tik-tok you know just everything starts
and you just it's coming to you you're a
passive
it's very passive and you're able to
literally go into a specific
psychological state where you don't
actually have to process anything you
can just let it come Steve Jobs used to
talk about television as this this
ultimate machine to turn your brain off
tell me how Instagram or tik-tok or any
of these tools are any different you're
putting yourself you're putting the user
in a place it's almost catatonic once in
a while you'll drop a variable reward
like you know alike or super like or a
match or you know something you know on
Twitter you know you got a ton of
retweets and you get that great that
dopamine that serotonin Rush Rhees ah
that's fantastic you know I feel good
but in general what are we doing we're
going into a specific place where people
just want to be let alone left alone and
they just want the content that come to
them they don't want have to think about
it
so no mind is the act of creating both
products where they don't have to think
and then all these decision trees that
don't make people feel like they're you
know putting a ton of intelligence
against the decision what is really
shocking is when we talk about
television there was an entire
generation of Americans really around
the world but it was how about America
specifically that when they got home
from work the way they relaxed was they
sat in front of television right they
turned it on and they sat there yep and
that said eteri state was turning off of
the brain and passive consumption and
they just whatever the cable provider
decided they should watch they watched
that's exactly right exactly what's
happening on it yeah to kind of toss
another framework at you without trying
to make this you know to to intellectual
what we talk about is these as cohorts
of attention okay so you think about
television this is probably if we
rewound time went to the you know early
90s we're talking about two and a half
hours sometimes people would sit down
then the desktop computer emerged that
was a you know you would you'd have like
45 minutes to an hour session maybe at
night at work you would have two hours
maybe in the morning an hour then you
have laptops it gets smaller and more
narrow then you move obviously to the
phone era
now we have like 14 to 24 minute
sessions per day so these are all these
new attention cohorts and now we have
this new one which is this you know
audio world that's emerging around
podcasting and air pods and whatnot
which is you know three or four
45-minute sessions and so the power of
any consumer application at that at a
given time is to pierce into that
attention stream find out and understand
what it is people want out of that set
environment and then deliver them these
amazing products so you know for example
you wouldn't long-form wouldn't work on
mobile right we went to this world where
everything is Instagram stories and tick
tock and you see Hollywood trying to
make that jump but not really it's true
because guess what it's a new attention
stream it requires entirely new ways of
thinking about the customer new ways of
engaging the customer new creators
underneath it so it's this beautiful
sort of creative destruction cycle and
one of the things I look for in consumer
and one of the things that I pay most
attention to is these new attention
cohorts emerging because you know
sometimes they creep up on you you know
this podcasting in pair ear pods thing
it came pretty fast you know all of a
sudden six months ago people said wait a
second there's six million air pods out
there and podcasting is growing at this
rate how did that happen in two years
who knows where we end up
yeah and part of that when you look back
at what happened over the last let's
call it two years in the podcasting and
audio world there's two really three
things that stick out my mind one is the
air pods actually launched so people got
them in their ear realized wow this is
different even though there's just no
cord whole different experience right
freedom yep to is I actually think I'm a
Content creation side a number of people
got woken up when they started to hear
numbers like Joe Rogan's podcast both on
the revenue and the viewership side etc
and so it was like wait a minute I
thought that was this little small thing
this is massive and then the third thing
is actually the content subjects started
to prefer it so if you look around now
and you say whether it's CEOs of
companies entertainers all these people
they actually are starting to choose to
go on to this medium versus the
chose or else it so there there's a lot
of good stuff there first
today voice is not a platform it's an
interface it could become a platform but
it's an interface it's a dang good
interface what has to happen for it to
transition from an interface to a
platform there has to be much more
connectivity on the developer side there
has to be ways in which you know
specific api's exists for people to hook
in like there has to be this nexus this
community right now it's still pretty
closed can't do much with air pods
podcasts are locked in these arcane RSS
enclosures I mean this is still pretty
you know RSS was invented 20 years ago
so the interesting thing about where we
are today is sort of backing up for a
second thinking about audio why is audio
so great first ridiculous amounts of
information density second ridiculous
amounts of human you know what makes us
who we are the intonation the the you
know the pitch all these things that we
forget like we've been living in this
text world which is incredibly
transactional why do emojis exist they
exist because we needed to add sort of
sort of a human layer to that I don't
think you need audio emojis maybe a
little bit it could be fun and the third
and this is the most important and I
think if you want to talk about Joe
Rogan unlocked yoga Rogan for you right
now multimodal consumption people are
listening to Joe Rogan while they're
driving a forklift while they're you
know you know digging a ditch sitting
there in a tollbooth whatever it may be
driving a car walking to work walking to
work
yeah literally shooting baskets you can
do you can listen to audio consume audio
in a no mind state in a multi-modal
environment meaning driving walking we
weren't working out potentially sitting
there on your on your work laptop you
know in Excel and so I think what people
forget about audio is how flexible it is
and you look at video right and video
had this amazing curve to it with
YouTube and whatnot and Instagram and
snap but you know you still hear people
day like oh I don't want to get my
camera like it's there's an
uncomfortable it's uncomfortable
it's very takes all of your attention
you really have to focus with audio you
can do whatever you want I cook twice a
week you know what I'm doing
listen to podcast half the time you know
I'll read a book and listen to the
podcast at the same time it sounds
incredibly crazy but my brain can
consume that way and I think I'm not the
only one so I used to listen to music
exclusively when I worked out I pretty
much don't listen to music at all
anymore it's either audiobooks or
podcasts right and what I think happened
if I try to be someone intellection
honest is audiobooks came first Yeah
right and it was an easier transition to
go from I don't have time to read right
now I'm moving I'm doing something
whatever let me just have somebody read
to me yeah so okay that's pretty clear
and then now we've transitioned into
well like what if it doesn't need to be
a book what if it can be more an
interview somebody just talking in 20
minutes whatever it is and so what
probably has occurred as content
consumption has gone through the roof
right however you want to measure that
but what it's doing as well as its
changing the type of content right going
back to your idea of like if we were
such a text-based world we added emojis
that's kind of an evolutionary Taisha
how do we get a motion into this now all
of a sudden you take that same content
somebody reads it it's a whole different
experience right not only from what
you're doing but also the the way that
the content is presented to you ends up
being very different and what I think
happens is we're just the beginning of
that the content creators haven't even
really figured out yet how do I create
the content to best live on this
interface your Papa shredder burns of
becoming when they get that right this
thing's going to take off yeah you know
what's interesting is I don't think
we're not to contradict you but I don't
think we're arriving anywhere I think
we've been here for 200,000 years humans
started the art of storytelling around a
fire 200,000 years ago that's how we
shared information sure there was cave
art you know 40,000 years ago or whatnot
but for a very long time this was
codified into our DNA and I have this
thesis though it's unprovable I think
the last decade I call it the eyes down
decade or the glass decades so it's like
oh six to 20 we've been burying our
phones transactionally communicating
with text text is
great at certain things you know grab my
keys
here's the room I'm in here's a cell
phone number really great but that human
emotion that thing that drives us that
makes us excited and sad and happy
elated like text is not good at it
it never was good at it but we've been
conditioned for the last 15 years
because this is where the tools were at
and now we're sort of unlocking or
pulling back the onion again so again I
don't think this is traditional I think
the technology and the stack underneath
it it sort of certainly new but I think
the behavior is absolutely like part of
our DNA when you think about that's
where we're at today walk me through how
you analyze the various aspects of audio
right so there's obviously communication
but then there's just kind of you know
single-player consumption where somebody
is creating content that I'm consuming
are there other things in that category
or is it pretty much just I can
communicate or I can consume one way um
yeah there there's a lot of striations
to this I mean it let's let's not forget
outside of texting and photo sharing
probably the most prominent activity on
the phone is still calling so calling is
audio I mean it's old and it has the
ring and the buzz and the address-book
and all that stuff that's no fun but
audio it works it's works it works and
it's it's still a scale behavior but I
think what we're gonna see happen what's
going to emerge is these form factors
that fit into people's lives in
different ways for example I love your
podcast I find it interesting I'm not
gonna listen your podcast when I have 20
minutes this is two hours on a Saturday
or Sunday throw my air pods in take a
walk around the block I know I have that
window but there are other times in the
day say I wake up where you know I may
want something choppier faster give me
you know some business yes I'm a burst
of information and I think we can't sort
of negate the fact that how we connect
with humans mostly is through talking so
there's gonna be something really
important bi-directional there as well
and so audio is going to
find its form factor in all these
different cohorts of attention and I
think the thing that's also most
interesting is this the impact of Hira
Bowls cannot be tonight I mean you talk
a lot about the creation side like Joe
Rogan you Sam Harris there's a bunch of
people producing incredible content
outside the media machine but now talk
like sort of back up for a second and
just look at like this is like a
kaleidoscope of opportunity there's so
many different places to basically
create products and services where
people can do it on their time talk a
little bit more about the hero bowls
like what yeah so the hero bowls so I
think here bowls are really fascinating
when Apple launched air pods around 2
and a half years ago they were
universally panned shows you what
consensus
you know what consensus knows I think
it's safe to say I've studied Apple
pretty aggressively for last 10 years
almost every day I think this is
probably the second best product they've
ever launched there were people that
thought that the watch was potentially
more important to you know the overall
business but I think air pods can are
now in that pantheon of right behind the
air the iPhone and when I think about
hero bowls and I'm using air pot as a
proxy but there's plenty of competitors
what you have is this amazing world
where the computing is inside you and a
lot of people bet on the computing being
on your face and what we've learned
about items and hardware on your face is
that a lot of people don't like that
yeah you're talking about like glasses
glasses like helmets heads-up displays
all that sort of stuff that because
visual literally includes your vision
yep and I think the key is humans for
many many years did not have things on
their face other than sunglasses right
so then to put this like really heavy
architecture with circuits and this that
and the other like on your in front of
your eyes really really hard really
really hard to people do that to have to
digest so you think about like where are
the computing paradigms right there
something in your hand there could be
something on your face and now there's
something your ears but when you have
like people are pretty much okay with
having something in their ear it's not
something that like bothers them
and so what Apple got so well it's just
this idea of they're just the best at
hardware and services and putting them
all together right they made this like
pretty well a beautifully designed
device put in your ear
it worked magically with your phone now
your phone is an edge server in your
pocket and all of a sudden you feel free
and I think people looked at here obols
first as a cordless identity he said oh
that's a cordless thing and as you said
like it's kind of hard to explain until
until you use it but it's so much more
than a cordless piece of hardware it's
an entirely new way of thinking about
the world
yeah don't realize it until you try them
yep the freedom component because you
literally just think oh it's just you
just remove the cord from the phone to
my ear but it changes everything that
you would do with headphones when you
remove that cord it's it's undeniable I
think the other thing is so fascinating
is you know the trajectory of Technology
always goes from big medium small to
invisible that's that's the way
technology works if it isn't rendered
invisible at the end it's probably not a
great piece of technology and you think
about communication you think about
information consumption it just keeps
going down this curve smaller smaller
smaller smaller and now we have it in
the ears
it's almost invisible we're not at near
a link yet that's probably six years out
but I think that that's the end state of
this like yeah I literally the I air pod
or as competitors are as close to an
embeddable as we're gonna yeah I don't
get the imagine I think right now if you
look at like we're near Alex stands on
sort of a continuum and where the where
the phone is as an edge server I think
earpods perfectly bisect that moment I
think it's gonna be an incredible ride
for them tons of new services but again
getting back to core human behavior we
don't want a bunch of technology all in
our stuff we want to feel free and I
think it took air pods and it took some
time like six if it wasn't a year before
people really understood how good these
things were to realize you know what
it's really nice to not have to
this bulky device somewhere a laptop or
a tablet or whatnot do you think that
when you and I have always talked about
an audio is kind of the the thought
process or kind of this you know
hands-free type experience face up eyes
up excetera
yep but as I'm sitting or thinking about
it the voice interface with the Google
homes the Alexa is that you know
whatever the device is already Siri to
some degree but but really kind of
in-home devices you've also changed the
way that now you're communicating with
the technology yeah so you bring up an
interesting thing about Alexa's and and
whatnot and I'll present to you kind of
a user experience case study the people
who love Alexa's are very young a very
old and it tells you something about the
strength of the environment the
strengths of the tool these are people
who are probably less concerned about
computing right these are just people
who are doing something functionally and
so you know my nine-year-old daughter
can use Alexa flawlessly she does
homework with it my parents use it you
know seventy-five years old you think
about sort of the barbell there and it
tells you about how versatile this new
interface will become and I other thing
I think about that's interesting about
voice that isn't widely distributed or
thought about is this idea it works in
environments and thrives and
environments that people don't talk
about very often what about Android auto
or car play I mean a captive a captive
audience and experience where people are
basic basically have hours on end to
turn off their brain
everyone commuting these days is just
listening to interesting podcast and
Spotify and they're mixing it together
and pretty soon all of this stuff like
let's be honest the voice technology at
least you know presenting commands to a
piece of hardware it doesn't work that
good it's still not that great Google
has the best technology today by far but
it's still clunky but where will we be
in five years when when it actually
understands true natural language
doesn't matter what dialect it doesn't
matter what's going on in the background
or what noise when it when a computer
can truly understand your intent and you
have you can do it effortlessly all
sorts
new things happen so the one thing about
a consumer Internet is every time you
reduce and make something more simple
amazing things happen does the phone
eventually disappear like can we get the
phone itself I said you know what I get
asked this question a lot I think the
phone has tremendous utility ok um it's
still a great device for getting work
done it's still a great device for
consuming video and until we have a new
display a true display I think the phone
is here to stay but I think it's a
beautiful compliment it's like peanut
butter and jelly
I believe the phone will fade away much
like sort of the the the the actual much
like the phone did to like the laptop or
the tablet like I mean there's a joke
around Silicon Valley about like running
your business off a cellphone like I
don't want to touch a laptop do I think
you could run a business off your air
pods probably not not in the foreseeable
future but I think it just diminishes
that attention we know on bigger devices
like the phone but I've been saying all
along so think of the phone again as an
edge server it's this powerful device in
your pocket can do lots of things can do
a lot of compute but it mostly stays in
your pocket yeah one other device that
I'm really fascinated by and I think it
kind of intersects with a lot of these
voice and audio except you're and visual
is things like mirror right these kind
of in home gym apps that there's the
entertainment component there's a
functional component of I'm actually
working out yeah but I can see something
that isn't actually real right in terms
of it's not a real trainer human
standing there tell me but there's this
kind of virtual person that just working
with me and I have a very unique
relationship with it right because I it
it's almost like a coach right or or a
boss telling me to do something and I do
it and some some what I work for the
machine right to some degree how do you
think about that in this world of kind
of more passive consumption and the
technology really kind of again going
big to small to invisible how does that
work um well if you think about it what
the mirror is just miniaturizing is that
that workout facility where you know 40
people are riding on a bike this is back
to the thesis again of it getting small
potentially
visible at some point so it's taking
this you know you know a class
environment and making you feel like you
know you're doing it even though it's
really single-player so it fits the
matically along that same line and I
think the interesting thing is we've
been blessed in the last 15 years with
really bringing production quality up
like you don't need a Hollywood studio
to do this stuff again so if you think
about sort of the value chain of of the
product
everything's getting better the hardware
is better it actually looks like a real
mirror doesn't look like some crappy
device you know in the corner the the
video fidelity is unbelievable it's you
know I mean some point be all 4k it
looks like it was shot on the Warner
Brothers lot yada yeah that the speakers
are great like every piece it's the
cumulative effect of all of these
technologies obviously networked
underneath it that then create this
experience that could never existed and
I've heard a lot of stories about
peloton I'm not an investor I don't have
one but I think it's a cool it's a
really cool device I heard people the
early days saying like it was such a
hard leap to think like a tablet on a
bike with the service and video was
gonna work and he had to presumably make
like six things connect and he did but
look what happened
it's like this magical experience we
feel like you're actually in one of
these boot camps or class but you're
doing it outside or you're doing in your
garage or your you know your bedroom
it's it's it's it's amazing yeah
so there's a big difference between
building hardware products software
products and then combining them on the
software side how do you think about
kind of product design in today's world
right so you know 10 15 years ago kind
of pre iPhones or longer attention spans
you know all kinds of different
components to society in the way that we
interact with technology today looks a
lot different kind of how do you walk
through as you're building a product
here's the things to pay attention to
here's how to actually design the
product to be successful well I think
there's a lot more cultural landmarks
now people understand the true talent of
like a Tony Fadell a Johnny I've yves
behar
like these are people that like normal
people within the industry respect and
admire so there is a total
pull if you will and you can look up and
say look that person designed the nest
wow that's amazing
good design is always going to is always
going to be scarce and it's a function
of many many many different things
there's an aesthetic discipline there's
people understand weight size they
understand work with certain materials
their interface designers graphic
designers user experience designers like
there's all sorts of stuff but I'll say
the bar now is through the roof design
even ten years ago couldn't hold a
candle to what it what is today and even
twenty years ago you know someone posted
the other day on Twitter you know the
loading animation where the the paper
was going into like the this little like
that they every have been and they Danny
trend called it the greatest animation
on the Internet it was like that was at
one point high design and so design is
accelerating people are getting better
but it's multi-discipline now there
isn't like one way to say like oh like
it really requires a really in totality
someone has an unbelievable aesthetic
sense and that that will never ever ever
be a commodity how do you balance kind
of a design driven world where human
intuition human decision-making is
really important and my words not yours
but you got almost have to feel what the
right thing to build is how do you
balance that with this world of like
data-driven iterative development where
hey we're gonna run a bunch of tests and
then the computers gonna tell us the
answer and let's make this change this
change this change right so um there is
no right answer to this it depends on
the DNA over the organization and the
people it's the composition of the
people so if you look at for example
snap Pinterest Apple you're talking
about high design like people who
literally the founders of snap designers
I mean this is this is something that
they hold very very true to themselves
same thing with Pinterest so I think it
starts at the top and set its a tone
when you come from a design or you know
it when you come from a
multi-variant product
is this massive math problem
organization you know it in each you
know being that type of Ord for Google
was an incredible competitive advantage
when they were trying to test all the
different ways of doing actions because
that was the type of skill set you need
it but then fast forward and you look at
like the snap era that's much more of a
painter with an easel and some you know
beautiful watercolors everything there
is basically just a tapestry of
creativity it's people trying stuff and
you know I don't think there's a right
or a wrong but I certainly know what
side I'm on yeah it you started do a lot
more investing yeah um when you're
looking at these early stage teams do
you look for kind of this founder
product fit right like like do you try
to tease this out is this more of a
data-driven versus a design driven and
this is the type of problem they're
going after and there's a certain
approach they ask explicit questions
about it but all I need to know is I if
I look at their materials I look at the
web page and I speak to the founder for
five minutes I can tell and so this is
not something where it's sort of
pass/fail it's the composition of all
the different artifacts that they share
with me where I make my investment
decision if I see something extremely
beautiful I know what type of team this
is also on the other side if they say oh
we really need a designer can you help
us find a designer or this great product
person I know exactly what they're not
so it does factor in and I feel like I
get lucky when I find a great design
sort of first startup if there is any
out there please hit me up I feel like I
get lucky when I find them but it's not
something you encounter every day why do
you feel like you get lucky well first
is like when you have the eye you can
identify it and so it's because it's not
everyone it's just a function of seeing
a lot of deals and I'll say this the
design var and the overall product
experience bar is nothing better and
better and better
I mean some of these SAS websites are
beautiful I mean this is you know like
seven eight years ago you know it was
like 19 1999 Yahoo says I'm yeah
this I mean I'm a stripe or clear bit or
any sites and I'm looking at them I'm
like these are these are pieces of art
going back to tinder how much iteration
and data kind of testing did you guys do
versus you know a lot of the design
product thinking a you're talking about
earlier we we got better at testing
later later in the history of the
startup a lot of it first was purely
intuitive really yeah the founders of
tinder were Shan Shan and and he just
had this innate feel for what made sense
it was it was almost just again it's the
note you know what when you see it kind
of vibe and him and Jonathan's sort of
ability to kind of understand the swipe
and to create a card structure that felt
alive that was all Design Thinking
there's all first principle design stuff
there was no you know prior art we're
gonna go do XYZ because this worked over
here it was purely intuitive but again
good design allows you to go into a no
mind experience it allows you to go into
this almost transcendental state and
when you go into that state what are you
doing you're giving your time you're
giving your attention and it's this kind
of like whole virtuous loop where if you
can do that over a protracted period of
time and keep people happy you know for
weeks months sometimes years you develop
something you know a franchise that you
know lasts for decades
yeah talking to me about kind of all the
work with AngelList and spearhead you
spend spending a lot of time on that
what's going on there so you know
AngelList has always been at the
absolute cutting edge of venture capital
and that's why I was an angel investor
and board member now live all Navy I
think saw the industry with extreme
clarity a decade in advance so they you
know that classic tome of you go to the
future and then you come back and you
develop it for the people of today
that's what they did so they were a
decade ahead and still are and I think
fundamentally venture capital it's been
around roughly speaking since the 1960's
has not seen a lot of innovation but
things are really starting to accelerate
right now and if you think about the
impact of Y Combinator and you think
about the impact of AngelList and the
amounts the sheer volume of capital
flowing into startups it's it's a whole
new world you know right now there's
about 600 unicorns on the book and I
believe someone said to me that don't
quote me on this but it was seven eight
years ago there was like 35 how many
private companies are gonna be worth a
billion dollars in 2030 more than 600
more than it more than 600 and so
fundamentally reshaping venture capital
to be more entrepreneurs centric is like
been my goal and always and I I the
first person I ever met in the valley
that was an investor was Ron Conway and
if anything know anyone knows anything
about Ron Conway it's it was
entrepreneur first and that's old-school
I don't know if everyone believes in
that anymore but I sure do and navall
and navy AngelList and now spearhead
which is our program where each year we
we give up to a million dollars to 30
leads these are founders who are in
market with Series A B and C companies
so actually that we have some in this
class as a public company and we give
them a million dollars to seed
investments and their friends and the
people in their network like the best
proxy for success in venture capitals
find someone who knows what they're
doing and they distribute money to fight
with their friends now sometimes that's
hard to do because people are in and out
of jobs and you know maybe they're
locked in or they got handcuffs or maybe
they you know they they're going to Bali
for two years and deciding to find find
some peace or to Mordor yeah
Iceland Iceland right take your place so
the thesis here is that we wanted to
create a frictionless environment with
spearhead to enable founders on the
ground to fund the most interesting
people and projects at the very early
stage and these are that process that
those people being funded right so
whoever you give the million dollars to
that lead whoever they end up funding
those individuals would go to other
founders first and have a different type
of conversation they're going to
investors founders on the ground want to
deal with other founders period
other founders know what's going on they
understand the challenges they
understand the stresses that it puts on
them they want to go to other founders
and and I've I don't think I've ever met
a successful founder that didn't have at
least a small cohort around them visits
it's this is an issue of mental health -
it's staying saying someone to call so
why shouldn't that person also be able
to identify key talent in market or soon
to be in market it could be even pre cap
table we have this idea now where we
want to fund people within our lead
structure where their best friend might
not be ready to leave his job here's 50
K to leave your job that's not even a
joke that's that's something that we're
actively pursuing so pre cap table
investing gas Nate's me yeah um and it's
literally the idea of you don't have a
company yet but you're the right person
that's good and it goes back to you know
when I first started investing a number
of different people in some form or
fashion said at the end of the day early
stage investing comes down to back in
the best people because everything else
that they're telling you is going to
change what they're building the market
conditions are competitor all those
other stuff can change but if that
individual is good they'll find a way to
win and you guys are almost taking that
idea and putting it on steroids and
saying you don't even need the company
if you're the right person there's
somebody there who could fund it yeah
we're systematizing you and we're
building an institution around it all we
needed to do was rewind the tape and
look at the Vintage of like oh six to
twelve and our peer groups and I mean we
have you know five to ten billion dollar
companies in that peer group and at that
point capital was someone hard to get
access to someone had to run your
back-end so you know you're you would
have to pay a lawyer then you'd have to
figure out how to deal with the filings
with the SEC and whatnot it was very
very complicated
I mean angel investing ten years ago
there was only three or four people out
there doing it you know Ron Conway Mike
maples I mean it's a small group of
people and the reason why is it was just
a it was in it financially was not
possible so again reduce friction find
people who already have that access and
then give them the ability at times to
fund people that
and you mentioned it best like things
change everything changes all the most
complicated and biggest businesses of
our time have went through severe you
know 180s in their sort of gestation
period but that's okay when you're
betting on a person and you're betting
on someone you trust and you know that
they can potentially get through that
you know cross that chasm and at that
next level of fifty to a hundred
thousand dollar investment early stage
is an absolute incredible option on the
future yeah and but I think also what
we're seeing too is just the entire
venture capital industry is just being
completely reshaped you know we had Y
Combinator that is done absolutely
worlds for Entrepreneurship and you had
the soft Bank incursion which you know
hasn't really played out it's unclear if
it was you know good or good bad or
terrible but it certainly has had its
ups and downs right lately and now you
have this whole new cohort of investors
coming in on both sides so if
institutions who are coming in and
bypassing VCS and are doing secondary's
direct and trying to build structured
products to get access to private
companies and then from the bottom you
have this whole class of investors who
are now able to raise funds smaller
funds five to 15 sometimes 20 million
who have experience in market we're
basically becoming you know the the pro
VC's but they're not VCS they're just
individual fund managers so this this
market for you know for venture capital
where it used to be you know seed ABC
you know public like the notion of all
of these stages and intervals like it
doesn't even like compute anymore I
can't even keep up with all the
different
pre-seed pre cap seed seed plus seed
extension and it's because there's so
much capital there is so much capital
there's so much opportunity upside in
the market everyone sees it and guess
what public market investing as you know
is it's just not as sexy people have
seen these Airbnb and uber z-- and
SpaceX and lifts and they say I want a
piece of that too so everyone's going
for it well and and we've got a friend
who I won't name some I'm not sure if
they're comfortable with it or not yet
one of their ideas is basically why why
is this happening right and the way that
he articulates it is basically what
better thing to do than to give money to
a highly entrepreneurial innovation
driven team yeah and have them go work
to grow it Yeah right and that same
sentiment from kind of a venture type
investor these echoed in a lot of the
data that we see in large institutions
right so if you look at whether it's the
Dietrich foundation in Pittsburgh Yale
etc the very high level of allocation
percentages in their portfolio to
private alternative investing right or
there is traditional private equity
venture capital etc and I think for a
long time that's kind of been taboo in
the institutional world but that
conversation drastically used to see a
pejorative saying you were going down
market it was like well what are you
gonna do you're rolling your sleeves up
to go deal you know with a bunch of
people in a garage but that all changed
with the last decade and and I think
let's be honest this is just the pursuit
of yield everyone's going after yield
the public markets it's even in this
bowl it's still really hard to come by
very concentrated so if you think about
sort of asset allocation theory and
you're being smart about it of course
you're gonna go down market you're gonna
cut out a lot of these people that were
charging you to in 24 and you're gonna
go direct and it's happening on every
side I mean half of these operator angel
funds are funded by institutions so
they're coming in below and they're
coming in on this side what's your take
on kind of this idea there's been a
couple of people who have recently said
look the venture capital institutions
are the very top ones will always be
around yeah and kind of continue to
thrive but the next wave of really good
investors are actually going to be where
founders want to take money from the
individual rather than the institution
yeah I think it's already happening I
mean like you look at the compounded
success of a Sequoia or Excel or a
benchmark I mean they're not going
anywhere and it's an incredible brand
and it means a lot if you get Series A
funding for consumers startup from
benchmark this is hype attend
so that the outcome for this company is
in the multi billions um so agree with
the first part of your thesis second
part is it's just this is back to no
mind human nature yours you're gonna
start up you're working hard do you want
to take money from someone who has no
idea and they're just basically you know
kind of like an institutional money
manager that plays golf at four o'clock
and it doesn't understand or empathize
with you or do you want to take money
from someone who just did it who just
scaled or you know was the lead growth
at blank or have you know has a
incredible eye for customer acquisition
and can tell you everything about
customer acquisition onset this platform
and that platform of course you're gonna
go to someone who gets you and those
people just weren't there because of all
of the issues associated with raising
funds but now they are and I think it's
only growing I mean one thing I've
noticed too is a lot of these people
that are helping companies are really
young really young like late 20s early
30s and you ask yourself well do they
have the wisdom and experience knew this
job and the answers I don't know maybe
they do maybe they don't but what they
do have is a human connection with the
founder well and I think actually what
I've seen is a lot of those people not
only have the connection with the
founder they actually have experience
not whether it's good experience or not
can they translate yeah kind of give
good advice that's different but many of
those people you know I'm 31 and I
literally ran one of the growth teams at
Facebook yeah where what are the biggest
products right and so when you think
about that the there's a hundred people
like me sure that we're at Facebook ooh
BRR you know Pinterest Airbnb you just
go down online all of them
and so again doesn't mean they're gonna
give good advice but the fact that those
large companies whether they were small
and then grew or they were large let
those types of people who were younger
and had less experience in those roles
it's almost like they've accelerated
that that that kind of yes right in
terms of well if you have the experience
then you start to invest if you start to
invest and you goes well you continue
investment advice etc and that's been
the secret of Silicon Valley for a
really really long time
that's the ethos of the valley and so
it's again productized institutionalized
and I think you know in a broader
perspective
Capital is always looking for yield and
always looking for talent anything that
gets in the way of yield and talent is a
problem and the wall used to be 20 feet
high
maybe it's 4 feet high soon enough if
sort of the vision of angellist is
realized is it's just you're gonna put a
deal on the platform it'll be funded
with all high quality individuals that
you that you love immediately you'll say
if they get their pro rata rights or not
the money will be wired in 72 hours and
you're gonna be in business yeah and you
know listen I'm not sure if we need a
purely digitized the world that's not
what I'm trying to point out is the
future vision it's just the idea of
accelerating talent towards a vision and
getting rid of all of these draconian
arcane rituals of going in and pitching
and spending you know two or three
months and having people pull term
sheets and put them up or distract these
are distracting and the best
entrepreneurs also oftentimes aren't the
best at that endeavor and and so you
think about how many great companies
have been missed because the founder
wasn't that person or or I'll flip it on
you not only the ones that were missed
how many companies got funded because
the founder was good at that game and
not good at building the company right
right that numbers probably probably
bigger because people have have really
kind of understood now how the games
played it's well my favorite things I've
read recently is a Paul Graham wrote
this piece learned to unlearn and he's
talking about in school everyone's told
you know we're gonna go to class at the
end there's a test that tests if you
want to study for it doesn't rely on you
reading like the best books on American
history right and getting the actual
knowledge and then you you get a good
grade the test is reliant on did you
read the notes of the teacher gave you
right and that those may be good notes
bad notes might be the right information
might not be but that's how you pass a
test and so when people go into Y
Combinator what he sees as people
basically ask okay the test is
fundraising right because I have to
fundraise to be successful give me the
answer to the test how do i fundraise
and he's like look I could sit there and
I could tell you you know okay go to 20
you know companies or funds here's the
deck structure like here's all the
little you know
cortical cheat codes to doing this these
but actually the right answer is build
something that people want sure if you
build something people want they'll be
throwing money at you yeah and well
that's the reductionist answer but now
the tools are in place I mean we have
any begin to scratch the surface of like
how it's so much easier to build high
quality startup than it was 10 years ago
why do you believe that there's
everything from you know AWS to all of
the amazing collaborative tools that we
have I mean just the ability to ship
daily and use a product daily and get
feedback and understand what customers
want like it used to be you had to build
something and then he would launch and
you would do a commercial launch with
that it's an agency you didn't hope and
pray that anyone cared it's like this is
the it's the opposite of what people are
doing today because everything has been
streamlined there's software for
deploying there's software for testing
there's all these great design
environments where you can actually look
and feel and touch and everything can be
you know you can actually put something
in your hand that isn't even code and
say like is how would this feel if this
worked it's just you know it's we're
just getting it we're advancing we're
advancing as a civilization the
technology is getting better faster
cheaper more invisible and that's why
600 unicorns will be a laughable idea in
10 years laughable what happens in this
idea of these private companies there's
so much capital right now they're
staying longer in the private market
sector they're not they're not going to
plug markets is that a function of just
kind of late cycle type behavior and
that kind of self corrects itself or is
that an actual trend that you think
persist over the next you know I all
bets are off when the when because this
is all really tied to the macro
environment so the windows open when the
stock market is doing well as we know
though the stock market and public
equity investors start to pay a lot of
attention during this we work face
because instead of wanting to buy pure
growth they wanted to they started to
think about the viability of the
business so that was some sort of
texture in the market it couldn't be a
good event predicted so I think this is
all kind of somewhat like trying to
predict the weather and may who knows we
know now right now that people value
good businesses like they always did but
they they really value good businesses
and if it's purely a growth story you're
gonna pay a discount yeah the
B&B situation bill Gurley was just
highlighting it and we're very small
investors through an SPV there but they
were doing fantastic they were
profitable the unit economics with gray
kind of growth looked great etc they
didn't kind of hit that window right and
what he's basically pointing out is they
just reported some numbers that aren't
horrible but they're not great right and
he's like look you get a we work
situation you get you know numbers
change and all of a sudden that window
closes really quickly or becomes less
attractive and I think what he was
highlighting was kind of this idea of
these markets don't stay in the same
factory that forever no it's totally
dynamic and I think one of the other
things about staying private for a long
time is the rules of the public
companies that how people think about
public companies get imposed on you
right and so they're staying private to
try to improve their numbers improve
their margins get their unit economics
in place get their growth numbers at
that level where everyone you know can
it can feel consistent
quarter-over-quarter but guess what
you know like just the rules changed and
when I remember when Ober went out I
mean remember before uber went out I
mean people were thinking it was gonna
go out at 95 billion 120 billion I heard
a hundred and fifty billion I believed
every bit of it at the time but now
sharpen the pencil so it's a dynamic
environment it's incredibly awesome to
be an entrepreneur money is flowing
access is flowing people are incredibly
excited to be on the ground floor and if
you're entrepreneur doing great things I
mean I want to hear from me because I've
never seen anything like what's
happening right now I don't know if it's
sustainable nothing is but the velocity
of companies the quality of companies
and just the sheer variance I mean it
used to be there was consumer and
software at consumer and enterprise and
a little hardware and that was kind of
like the world there's a mismatch of
everything now now there's companies
like notion where you know it's not even
clear whether it's a consumer company or
an enterprise company you know it's like
this incredible Cambrian moment in in
this startup cycle certainly it will
last forever prices not gonna last
forever but right now is an incredible
time but the one thing is if you're
starting a company it's great to get a
good price and get into your round and
start building your company but doesn't
matter it's gonna take 10 years anyway
you live in LA
mm-hm there's a lot of magic in Silicon
Valley yeah are you in LA uh well I used
to live in Silicon Valley and still kind
of think of it as my second home la it's
just creative it's interesting I like
the beach I like to surf so there's
other things in my life besides
technology but I think that la ecosystem
is really blossoming
I've never compared it to Silicon Valley
and I never liked the term silicon beach
because it makes an immediate inference
happen I don't like that I just LA is
its own thing and as incredibly creative
people you know Elon is doing his thing
down now Peter teal is doing his thing
down there like we really are in this
like new phase and I can tell you that
for about 120 years the studio system
reigned supreme in Hollywood it was all
studio system actors producers people
who you know helped on set and it feels
like in the last five years it's just
evaporated and why I think the
technology business came in and there
was winners you know you have snap you
have tinder again SpaceX and I think you
know again you look for sort of these
cultural idols right it's like if snap
did it there we can do it there and so
you get this new kind of class not only
aspirationally but you get it off kind
of the edges of the company because the
great engineer leaves the great designer
leaves and so we're now starting to see
you talk about the flywheel is the
flywheel effect happen in LA which is
people have been successful maybe not
the founders are now spinning off to do
their own thing I think the other trend
it's kind of interesting to point out is
a lot of amazing people from San
Francisco are migrating to LA I mean I
think it's a it's a quality of life
situation it's across the living
situation and it's just purely a
different place that's different cool
but you get a ton of that intelligent
Intelligencia down and we used to have
this whole debate you know the debate
about Silicon Valley in LA and so I was
so far ahead and like you know what I
don't even think anyway I don't even
I've heard anything like that for the
last 12 months it just doesn't matter
anymore yeah do you think that that's
not just an LA thing you think it's more
of a kind of macro I totally believe
it's a macro trend but I think the
proximity makes LA just that much you
know closer to that that Silicon Valley
hivemind thing and I see a lot more of
the dynamics and ethos in the valley
starting to merge in the LA where
there's like people who just want to
help out you know that was a weird thing
in LA 15 years ago why does this person
want to help but that was something that
would happen in Palo Alto or so more
what not so you see that and I think
this is all just sort of like this
connective tissue like Berlin London all
these like startup hubs are emerging and
it just takes a couple of successful
companies and you know listen look we
have YouTube and we have Twitter and we
have all these amazing tools now where
everyone feels like they're getting
information at the same exact time where
that whereas before if the valley had
and always like had just a monopoly on
information and I mean I don't know what
I don't know so I'm sure the valley does
still have things that nobody knows but
those secrets are doing it yeah what
what is um kind of your thoughts around
this podcast stuff and kind of how it
intersects with the technology right cuz
yeah two of the things that I spent
spending a lot of time thinking about is
one all of the monetization around audio
is like 1990 type organization as you'd
expect yeah of course right people are
literally I do it right yeah literally
reading a a dream that's right and
there's no dynamic pricing there's no
dynamic targeting that there's none of
that stuff that's one and then two is
also the distribution of a lot of this
has not kept up with the multimodal the
hero Bowles there's a lot of innovation
going on there but the actual
distribution platforms themself Spotify
probably out in front of a lot of yeah
but everyone else seems to be pretty
stagnant what's kind of your thoughts
there yeah so a couple different things
to point out the first is monetization
tools always lag scale so scale happens
before monetization if it doesn't
there's something really really weird
about the market and that's almost never
happens maybe we'll see the day in the
future in crypto when it's all
integrated and happens at that same
exact moment the promise of
you know tokenizing everything and it
being like this just this is a unity but
that's not how consumer it has worked
for the last 30 years scale happens then
the tools come in because the companies
that want to service the scale get
invented get funded so when you think
about where we are in the curve right
now we're climbing up
I mean podcasting is still niche or
small it's still small exactly if you
look at it in comparison to terrestrial
radio it's it's it's a lot smaller but
it's climbing and you see this the moves
that Spotify is making and I think you
have to think about the distribution for
a second and how it how it exists so
first you know everything's been
basically an oligopoly between Google
and our friends over at Apple right but
now you have Spotify so you got three
companies that are kind of competing for
attention and that you know the the the
best place to be is obviously the rapper
the house right the the company that can
serve it up and then ask you if you want
the ads that's what everyone's trying
everyone wants that systems level
control I'm not sure if that will change
so much because they're still like
creators know that they need to be they
need to go through Apple they know that
you know you know literally you have to
go to Spotify you're like how many how
many hundreds of thousands of losers
users not losers sorry that was not a
Freudian slip how many hundreds of
thousands of users would you lose but I
think what what happens as this
technology matures and as this
form-factor matures people are gonna
find new ways to sort of sharpen the
blade so we think of podcasting right
now is this sort of like bi-directional
we're sitting in front of a mic or maybe
it's zoom that's what podcasting means
right now just like blogging meant
something in 2004 it was movable type or
type pad it meant like you sat in front
of an editor and all of a sudden Twitter
comes and what's Twitter is Twitter
micro blogging I don't know I'm not I
don't I go most doesn't even it doesn't
matter but what I'm telling you is that
when there's people excited about a form
factor incredible electric things happen
on the edges that you can't predict and
so right now we're doing something
like I said RSS was invented by dave
winer and adam curry in 20 20 years ago
so 20 years ago they've been working on
this they really weren't working on it
that much lately but back in the day so
it's 20 years old now we're at this like
inflection point where people like sam
harris you Joe Rogan are scaling right
but we're still so early on that curve
so podcasting as we know it fast forward
five years maybe 10 years I don't think
it looks anything like this yeah I mean
this form factor will exist but I'm not
saying in this exact rapper with this
exact distribution method so what's
crazy to me is I agree with you that
we're early yeah if you look at the
numbers of what you know Rogan is
probably the one that everyone knows
from the public numbers 2.5 billion
listen /downloads views longer and so if
you look at many of his episodes just on
YouTube million two million three
million views per video that would put
him as the most popular television show
on a nightly basis right and it's funny
to hear us say we're so early right
because it's already the top of this
kind of audio podcast excetra world is
eclipsing what is an old form factor but
he's also been at it for you know 10
plus years yeah right so it's it's not
like he's an overnight success he's put
in a lot of time and effort in building
this but for the overall podcaster audio
market to be so early and already see
some of this scale happening it's 10
years from now it's gonna be nuts so one
of the things about thinking about
Jack's another sort of framework that I
think about when it comes to product is
really trying to understand what real
people are doing and you know there
there's one sort of belief of follow
what the Nerds are doing on the weekends
Chris Dixon used to say that's a really
good place to start just whatever the
Nerds are doing productized the other
thing is keep your eyes open if real
people are actually doing something with
new tech and it's I'm like give me an
existing credibly curious I'll give you
an example so I went down to Guitar
Center in Los Angeles where real people
are yeah well yeah to pick up to pick up
some
- to pick up some stuff for a project
I'm doing and I went to the guy and I
said you know where's all the podcasting
stuff he said it's gone I'm like what do
you mean it's gone he's like we can't
keep it in stock we really just we put
it on we put it on the shelves it's gone
the next day
and I'm like well do you order more he's
like yeah we keep ordering more and he
keep selling it keeps disappearing and I
said well what are they buying like show
me the rig's base level you know hundred
$30
set up roughly we're not talking about
you know five thousand or fifteen
thousand dollar setups in a beautiful
place like this we for those that are
only listening we've got a new light in
here that that Joe ordered off of Amazon
and I feel like we're in like a new home
now right he smokes just like the Taj
Mahal so so there so you have except for
we have no art we got to fix the that's
like a prison cell back here but we're
gonna fix that so so you have real
people buying cheap hardware and what
are they doing they're starting their
own podcasts that's significant and this
isn't you know people who are trying to
find the bleeding edge to build the you
know billion dollar company and apply to
Y Combinator this is just kids in the
basement you know college kids you know
at UCLA and what I think is so
interesting about this trend is there
will be this is really the this you know
we always ask for the unbundling of
traditional media when's it coming and
what form factor and you know we saw
some of it with traditional media maybe
like Business Insider a BuzzFeed or
stuff like that but those things are
starting to feel like the you know kind
of like the parents if you will now we
have potentially hundreds of thousands
of people covering these specific niches
billing these beautiful you know
beautiful audience pools what does that
look like I mean it's it's it's
fascinating it's really fascinating you
said we don't know what it ends up
looking like right yeah and that is if
everyone knew what it was gonna look
like that would completely take off the
experimentation the innovation kind of
all the exploration that goes into
discovering it
to me well you know what I actually
think I do understand what it looks like
so I followed this podcast called desert
Oracle desert Oracle and it's this crazy
sci-fi podcast that this guy farms in
the room in Farbs laughing go by coin
mines yeah yeah that this guy can
basically conducts this sort of sci-fi
Meech future meets 50 years ago in the
past stories from the desert okay and
it's just this amazing electric podcast
it's so interesting and I don't know who
exactly listens to this desert Oracle
but if you put it on your like this is
amazing and he's gonna have this you
know thin I mean who knows if this
becomes a phenomenal maybe it maybe
doesn't it doesn't but my point is he
has this audience rabid fans that love
it and you'll when you when you listen
to it you'll know it it's and I think
for every vertical why can't that exist
for people who are interested in home
improvement fitness there should be
someone daily just talking about growth
stocks I'm sure there probably is but
well I mean this is what blogs did yeah
20 years ago yeah where you could almost
find other people who were weird like
you and interested in right nobody else
cared about yeah all of a sudden the
internet brought you a community right
if you could if they could discover you
you could discover them what you're
talking about is now you can do that
again in a new form factor and actually
this one's much more intimate there's a
voice in your head right this is yeah
yet another piece you know sort of
bullet my framework was everyone wants
to be a part of something no matter how
narrow mm-hmm everyone wants to be part
of something for some people's PTA
some people's yes yeah for the desert
Oracle crowd it's like you know weird
desert sci-fi they there are people like
you out there and someone will satisfy
you with amazing content because of
podcast it yeah and the other thing of
this too is we haven't even seen yet
like the quote-unquote great enter into
this yet yeah like when Disney comes
what the [ __ ] are they gonna do yeah you
know so maybe I'm a little less
optimistic about that I thought every
new creative landscape comes a new set
of creators that displace what we knew
as sort of you know the best of the best
so you know obviously there's the
youtubers on one side and now we have
the tick stalkers right and I'm not sure
if podcasting wants Larry King we have
Larry King right now and his name is Joe
Rogan and there'll be someone else and
there'll be a Mike Wallace and there'll
be an Oprah Winfrey and maybe they
already exist but my point is I think
I'm not sure if like the Disney model of
high production value matters here the
axis that matters here is an authentic
honest voice and someone that gets at
the truth and someone that builds a
community and I'm not sure that Disney
is any better than you so there's this
guy
Matthew Ball who used to be the [ __ ]
yeah head of strategy at Amazon Studios
and I read a piece that he wrote
recently and one of the things that he
brought up that I thought was really
interesting we said look these Studios
especially like the movie studios have
created movies then they've started to
try to take the movies and turn them
into TV shows or hair video games with
them etc and it's a multi-platform
approach to IP how do they basically get
this out yeah and so the one thing that
to me a Disney would be really really
well positioned to do but I don't I
don't have enough insight into the how
they work to know how they do it but
imagine if your kids could watch Mickey
Mouse they could play their games they
get stuffed animals etc and then they
could have somebody you with the Mickey
Mouse voice cover stories news what
right you almost take the character and
put it into this environment I agree
with you that just taking the Mickey
Mouse sure movie and saying hey I'm just
gonna rip the audio and put on a podcast
and nobody cares but if you can start to
almost personalize or humanize the
characters in a different way they're
the only ones who have the IP yeah no I
don't think it's I wouldn't deny that
they're capable of doing tremendous
thing
but I think again each new medium has a
form factor that strengths and as
weaknesses what our audios weaknesses
well you know you can't scan it it's
sometimes hard to get through it give me
long click yeah it's hard to click you
know we have speech-to-text but like no
one really wants to read a transcript
like that's not what audio is for so
audio has its own little areas that will
call them needs to improve right but
what audio is so good at this emotional
connection this this feeling of being in
this room together Disney will find a
way to make this just yet another
platform extension it will fit into
their entire offering their entire
portfolio you know they'll have the app
that does this and the game that does
that and the stuff animal and the
podcast piece will be right over here
and I I think though my belief is the
people who do the most amazing emergent
cool new things are gonna be people like
you experimenting on the edges and you
showed me something a few minutes ago
which I thought like I've never even
seen that before that mix of so there's
a guy Acura the dawn yeah who has
created he calls a meaning waves which
is basically mixing or overlaying audio
with a psychedelic music is how I would
describe it and so it's not a song but
it's not a pod can write it's gonna kind
of mix of somebody talking with music
underlying it I mean it's crazy it's
crazy I mean I heard I think someone
pitched me their day about they were
just gonna create essentially a near
real-time podcast of like everything
that's happening in their pursuit of
whatever creative endeavor they're doing
like documenting the entire thing but
bringing the audience in and he's gonna
do video with it as well
and I thought my stress justin.tv yes I
don't like justin.tv meets podcasting
you know and all that and I was like
that's crazy I've never seen that before
but I want to see it so it's it's a wild
world you watch um there's a new
documentary on a Netflix called the
pharmacist I have not so long story
short guy has a song he's a pharmacist
he's got a son his son
gets killed trying to buy drugs in the
Lower Ninth Ward in New Orleans he then
realizes hey the police aren't gonna
solve this he goes on this crusade is
and ends up being able to solve the case
guy goes to jail and then he doesn't
stop and realizes oh wait a second
there's an opioid epidemic happening he
finds the doctor who's writing all the
prescriptions like it's his whole thing
right so it's got kind of like a serial
yeah type like storyline to it but what
is absolutely nuts I mean this happened
I want to say like in the 2000s mm-hmm
he had an audio recorder and he did what
you're talking about
he never you know he recorded
conversations by phone he would just be
out walking be like you know I'm
starting to think that boom or whatever
and some of it sounded like he was note
taking a little bit but also like it was
almost like an emotional therapy didn't
wasn't talked to well what they were
able to do was get at this massive file
of audio content he had created you know
10 15 years ago and then they overlaid
with image or imagery and it's
incredible yeah I mean it is literally
like somebody in real time tell that
story and I'd never seen it before
like that that style but it's really
really [ __ ] powerful awesome yeah it
sounds great
I mean this is probably just like a tiny
little microcosm of what's gonna happen
yeah any areas that you're excited about
right now in tech that maybe people
aren't thinking about you know I'm I'm a
generalist so I look at a lot of
different stuff I'm I don't have a
particular vertical right now because
I'm kind of listen I I do a lot of
investing a lot I haven't seen tons of
consumer stuff I've done a few things
here and there I've been doing a lot of
FinTech investing but as we know the
FinTech window seems to be kind of
closing feels like there was an
incredible period of innovation starting
with Robin Hood and you know that that
seems to sort of be doing so i'm always
i'm mostly entrepreneur first i look for
interesting people if we want to call
them oddballs we can i don't know if
that's okay but I like I like people who
March to their own drumbeat and so
nonconformist attacking big markets good
science
good product background maybe maybe they
don't have both the same time but I
really look for people thinking
independently because as we know that is
really hard to do today it is incredibly
easy to fall into that conformist trap
and you think you're unique and you
think your thing is different but you
realize you're just like everybody else
and so I think the key variable is I
want individuals who see the world
differently and who are not afraid to
dedicate you know five ten years of
their life to pursuing that vision and
so you know we say this all the time
like you know what if we could find you
know even five of those people a year
wouldn't that be amazing it's hard this
is really hard work and we're doing a
huge velocity deals it it's trust me
it's so it's it's still a rarity two
questions and I'll let you go sure
thoughts on Bitcoin
I love Bitcoin what an answer yeah I
love Bitcoin I love Bitcoin for I think
of it I think of bitcoins of product I
don't think of it purely as a technology
I love the built-in scarcity I love the
idea of the decentralisation that a
network impact how the miner is interact
with individuals on the exchanges and
all these different parties that are you
know trying to get access to more
Bitcoin and I love I this is gonna sound
crazy but what I love about Bitcoin is
the type of talent its attracting for 20
years I've seen different waves you know
the SAS wave the consumer wave whenever
I start to see really smart young
developers paying attention and and
voting with their time and their money
to build products and services I pay
attention
yeah and so though there's a lot of
uncertainty about Bitcoin if you think
about how much you know debt there is in
the world today I think someone I think
last Oh 17 trillion dollars of sovereign
debt I look at Bitcoin is this like
amazing financial instrument but like
underneath it as a product it's just so
fascinating to me I mean it's like
especially like I the eight that this
the built-in scarcity is one of the most
interesting things I've seen happen and
tap
in forever and you know I've read
satoshis papers I spent a lot of time
thinking about the space and all I can
say is whoever invented Bitcoin was with
they weren't for ten they weren't there
were 50 years in the future it's just
it's it's amazing to me so anyone who's
built these technology products at scale
yeah when they understand bitcoin in
kind of its totality most people walk
away and just said it's beautifully
designed it's right it's like the
complexity that goes into a network like
this between the difficulty adjustment
and kind of the early seating the
founder stepping away I mean just all
these jobs like it's amazing Paula tree
yeah it's not technology it's poetry
it's it's it's one of the most
interesting things that I think has
happened and you know I'm the reason I'm
so optimistic and it's it's actually
really simple it's completely
reductionist I'm optimistic about
Bitcoin because young people are
optimistic about Bitcoin they trust it
that's all that matters that is all it
this is all that matters
one of my favorite memes I've seen on
the internet recently I saw one of these
stats I yeah let's say it's 17 trillion
dollars and it basically said the world
has 17 trillion dollars worth of debt
and I guess said who the hell does the
world owe we all owe each other money a
very complicated set of incentives
aliens believer or non-believer big
believer why you know I've read a lot
about the subject I want to believe
because in my meetings with desert or
yes I mean I'm a believer in it because
I am fascinated by the propagation of
technology from the 1960s forward so I
don't necessarily know whether or not
the aliens came with fiber optics and
semiconductors and heads-up displays and
oxygen devices and all these things so
there's a few good books I there's one
about Roswell I can't remember the title
I'll have to put that in the show notes
vodcast Romania's mother showed yeah
yeah okay but I'm fascinated by aliens
more so about the potential of what
could be and less so about this
conspiratorial side of the whole puzzle
and you know it's also something to
captivate your imagination because when
you're in technology you want to believe
anything is possible
yeah and so I've always been extremely
interested and I love ancient aliens the
show I mean listen what do you believe
well I definitely believe yeah so one of
the ancient alien researchers yeah
they're on the podcast and you know not
Erik fun Donegan no bruce fenton uh so
he had sixty seventy percent of it like
was very science-based hey there's
change at this time and all that stuff
what a little off the rails in my
opinion in terms of like you know there
was a crash with a spaceship and you
know that whole thing but one thing he
said to me just seared in my brain which
was every human has two questions are we
here alone and what happens when I die
he's at some point every single person
will ask those two questions in their
lifetime and what that leads to is Joe's
brother actually Alex we were talking
one day and he says to me probably the
most important discovery we as a
civilization could make is that there's
aliens right or some sort of intelligent
life that's fundamental if you think of
anything else like what I mean would
change your cancer or do our entire
disposition on earth it just it pails
anything else pales in comparison to
getting 100% scientific confirmation
that there is another intelligent out
there and I don't think that people
usually position that where you can't
ever make the conspiracy side of it a
lot of people like to focus on that well
that's also falling into this trap of
people can research that and this is
they believe it's knowable and and if
they're you know if they're a good
enough you know and it's loose yeah
internet sleuth akin they're gonna be
the ones that crack the code Tom DeLonge
the blink-182 talking along yeah I mean
he's got he's putting a lot of time and
effort into that and there's the tick
the the tic-tac video that they say is
being released because of some of his
research so I mean listen it's I find it
fascinating if not an interesting way to
go no mind
so I love it you get to ask me one
question to end this thing what question
you got for me okay uh he doesn't know
that's coming yeah I didn't know that
was coming
um what do you think is going to be the
first practical use case of BTC outside
of a store of value so I have two
answers to this the first is what's it's
actually public now second talk about it
um there's a company called zap that the
founder Jack Mahler's and his team has
built the ability for me to send you US
dollars across the Lightning Network so
I send you 20 bucks you receive 20 bucks
we know nothing about Bitcoin we know
nothing about what any network we know
nothing just Fiat de Fiat on the lining
rails what he's built is the cheapest
and fastest way for anyone in the world
to send money to each other so that
doesn't sound like a big deal to an
everyday person it's a big bids a big
deal when you think about Visa cash at
Ben Moy having the cheapest and fastest
way to send money around the world
he's like the Holy Grail sure right and
the way that he does it is very nuanced
and very technically kind of savvy etc
but what the reason why I bring that up
is one of the answers is because it
reminds us that there's a difference
between Bitcoin the asset or anything if
that is like lowercase B Bitcoin sure
versus Bitcoin the network the capital B
Bitcoin whoever named those two
shouldn't do such a hot job in terms of
deciphering the difference but we always
talk about the asset okay what can you
hold the store of value right and all
that kind of stuff but if you think of
the payment rails itself it's a
fundamental leap forward in technology
when you have a decentralized payment
rail that is actually faster and cheaper
than the centralized feature right and
it's no different than any other
technological evolution and other
industries etc the only difference here
is we can't point to somebody and say
you built it right or you owned it right
to me that use case is almost never
spoken about in terms of the rails but
sending fiat currencies etc across so I
think that's one that will kind of
surprise people and Jack's done a great
job there the other is actually country
to country trade transactions what I
mean by that is if I don't know anything
about them so like it's happened I think
there's been two of them so far
Argentina I believe has been involved in
both of them so Argentina traded I think
it was with Turkey he was very small
$7,000 $10,000 whatever was they bought
some pesticides from Turkey well if
turkeys lira is being screw around with
devalued hyperinflation you know what's
going on
and I as Argentina don't trust you as
turkeys currency well you also don't
trust me because same things happen to
my currency right we opted into
something that we both transparently can
see that neither one of us controls that
we can audit and know is verifiable so
that's who's been doing all the mining
well so that was one trade action
another transaction
I believe Argentina and Peru and is a
little bigger the other thousand dollars
something huh that type of transaction I
think is actually going to happen faster
than the kind of everyday retail and
user buying coffee or whatever and the
reason is to buy coffee with Bitcoin
today for you and I the dollar works
great right in most places in the world
there are some places where the dollar
doesn't work very well or hyperinflation
is occurring cetera but when you get
into the geopolitical game theory of
like I don't trust you you don't trust
me but we need to still conduct trade
that whole world feels really unexplored
right now and you're starting to see
like really it's not just Argentina
right you're sending Russia and China
and a lot of these people start talking
about getting off the dollar system etc
what I don't know is like is it a one
big country doesn't everyone follows
immediately or is it kind of one of
these like slowly you know and then kind
of all at once I'd I don't know how it
plays out but to me again
that's an inflection point in the use of
Bitcoin where you're now take
it from like speculative medium of
exchange to like dude there's countries
doing this and it's doing it for
something that's not just monetary value
it's actually a security or a confidence
tight ring I have one last question your
last guess was Jeff Lewis right yes who
has better hair for booed maybe the CEO
of coin mine or Jeff Lewis man this is a
hard question so we're gonna have to do
some sort of overlay in the background
that's we should I'm gonna say that they
both are the best in a different way and
here's why right Oh Mike this is called
hold on phoning it in no no here you go
I'm gonna make an accusation that I
think Jeff Lewis puts product in his
hair and far boot does not so you you
get two different answers of product or
no product we're gonna happen I really
hope that we can impose some sort of
visual where we will let them hear thank
you pop listen we're taking what where
can people find you on the internet yeah
I've never done this before
thank you if you're a founder Brian is
probably the best investor in terms of
literally pre cap table investing I
think there is nobody that I know who
can one be more helpful to you in terms
of product to what I'll just call the
game of building a company early so all
the things that aren't around product
and three the people he knows and the
people who he knows who respect his
opinion so if you're building something
you should absolutely go talk to them
now when you get all of those DMS and
emails you're gonna yell at me yeah yeah
but I genuinely mean that thank you very
kind of you best way to follow me is on
Twitter twitter.com slash Brian nor
guard Bri a n + o RG ard that's it no
email no cell you should give me your
cell phone number well well I want to
have I want to enjoy my I want enjoy my
quarter alright man thanks so much we'll
do it again